apparently North Korea's passport is
more powerful than ours right because
they can go to all these different
countries that we can't I mean I don't
know if you'd want to go to those guys
this will get you anywhere but you're
not going anywhere
[Music]
there's a dude named Raul Rodriguez he
says he'll never forget a moment that he
realized his life was built on a lie
whoa I know catchy isn't it this is a
dude this guy's dramatic man
fake adopted parents oh that's a that's
a pretty big lie you know what would be
good adopted very close but keep
guessing or did he [__] buy something
from Best Buy and he got the wrong thing
inside yeah no warranty you got
significantly farther away in a short
manner wrong things but life is alive
basically this is a dude I thought I had
a
he is a former he is a former General
Electric he's a former U.S Customs and
Border Protection Officer he's been
fighting uh
or not before he was funny he actually
was working to deport thousands of
people basically back into Mexico right
and uh back in April 2018 though Federal
investigators showed him a document
where uh he had a Mexican birth
certificate with his name on it whoa but
that name is very Mexican though it's
probably the most Being John Smith but
like Mexico version kind of but
basically this is this is an actual
truth uh a conversation with his father
afterwards confirmed that Rodriguez was
born in Mexico the U.S birth certificate
he'd used for decades was fraudulent
Rodriguez was never a U.S citizen and he
was an undocumented immigrant he's an
illegal immigrant kicking out
he's working for U.S customs dude that's
a tough job to want to have though you
know but he was to tr he was really a
believer that he was a U.S citizen yeah
but that's still a tough job like why
would you want that job did he [__]
turn back on his morals is he a
spineless [__] no he's like those which
part of him the one where he was working
at Customs border or after the fact no
like after he found out they stick to
his morals and keep deporting people
yeah oh all of a sudden I relate to
these guys
flip-flopping ass [__]
I feel like this dude is those kind of
guys that are like why couldn't they
just be legal like our family we did we
did it the right way yeah you know
they're like you guys go back take the
test like how we did it it and then now
he's like ah [__] we didn't do it yeah
yeah yeah well it wasn't just like oh
[__] we didn't know it's also like oh
because it was fraudulent of course he's
gonna give me that girl from US Customs
a border and then he was fighting to
stay in America bro isn't that crazy how
that works isn't that crazy how that
works is that not Karma dude in a lot of
weird ways like why I don't know man I
think that's just a tough job to wanna
that's it that is a tough job to like
like what if they were like all right
Joe you're now in charge of keeping them
dirty Japs out of the country like it's
like you're American but like God damn
that'd be like my pleasure
get out of here dude I'd rather work any
other job you know what's so dope about
Mexicans though what's so dope about
Mexicans is all the Mexicans he kicked
out on the Mexican side when he gets
kicked out they're like
[Music]
[Laughter]
the only reason why I would take the job
like let's say it was for my people's or
whatever right is I feel like I would
treat them better than if they're not
the same oh so like let's say the agents
are not Japanese they probably won't
understand the culture they'll probably
be like you just you it's easier to look
at different people and like dehumanize
them yeah so I think like I would take
the job because I feel like the Japanese
American Border yeah because you feel
like you'd be safe and then so just
saying rather than push them out of the
country I would just walk and escort
them gently out of the country
because I'd be like hey dude so this is
actually how you could do it legally and
kind of tell them but like next time you
can't come in versus like get the [__]
out of here you [__] yeah it's like I'm
a Japanese Beach Shack without the
Chinese
Joe would use the correct racial Epitaph
you know I'd be like sir sir they're
Japs okay they're nits they're chaps
all of that please you're offending me
come on Takahashi when I hear nip I
don't around because that's not me
that's not me you know yeah I like to
stick to yeah someone goes [__] I don't
turn around that's not me I'm not I'm
not Chinese man it's good it's cool
Rodriguez actually was also uh
apparently he served in the Navy as well
from 92 to 90. oh man he's a veteran too
yeah so what uh what an interesting
thing there's a loophole with that
though so like a legal loophole like if
you served in the American Military they
Grant you citizenship
so he has a case even with fraudulent
undocumented like yeah yeah you can uh
who's that to get your citizenship
because you've served the country like
you're you're a [__] Patriot and then
he could probably get his old job back
so you keep the party yeah
you're the first his first day back oh
thank God I could just import my own
people again the world is right again
that's kind of crazy but it got in when
I was out right
he can experience the whole he can
experience the whole system that other
people have to experience yeah because
then when you're on this side it's such
a different like you were born yeah like
it's you take that [__] for granted no
but what are parents or you know
ancestors had to do to come through it's
a complete it's a different race how
much money it takes yeah how much time
it takes how many lawyers you gotta hire
that don't do it right yeah
man I have a feeling though like if he
like got a citizenship through the like
the military thing and then if he were
to go back to his job I don't think he's
going to be more understanding I think
he's going to be extra mean to make up
for lost time really I because if he
goes back to the job he's got to catch
up on his numbers yeah he's got to catch
up but like if he goes to another job
then I think he'll be more understanding
like okay guys hey I was there on the
other side and it's not like that but if
he goes back to the same job then I feel
like he's gonna be extra mean and just
be like yeah that's nothing I did it
like you just go go back it's fine like
that's what I think is going to happen I
feel like the most Americans in America
like the most American Pride or the
newest immigrants that just got this 100
oh yeah they'll just bust out with their
Flags like when my parents got the flags
they just they save that plastic piece
of [__] flag that you get when you uh
get your citizenship yeah they did it's
a piece of [__] it looks like a flag
that you put on a birthday cake it's
symbolic I mean make it a better quality
piece of [__] elastic is like no raise
taxes so don't get better but the way
that they cherish that [__] I was like
yo you know that's like something they
just gave you as like a gag thing right
look at this wavy little piece of [__]
birthday cake but like I swear I swear
to God I thought they were gonna come
out in American jumpsuits in a hat like
top to bottom like Borat I thought they
were gonna walk out that way and they
couldn't stop
stop the whole [__] week I think it's
because our parents earned it yeah so it
was really hard for them so that for
them it's like we actually earned it and
then our generation and the one before
we're just born into it so here we just
kind of taking for class
all the white kids are all Communists
now with blue hair because they they're
like they don't remember yeah they don't
know what real comment is crazy that in
one generation that could happen yeah
one gen you have like proud to be here
fought so hard to get here next gen I
[__] hate this place yeah I think and
also our parents they walked with pride
because they knew as soon as they passed
they knew more about America than the
white people
yeah yeah yeah because they were forced
to did you know that test is hard
76. did you know have you guys ever been
to one of those uh like I don't know
what you call it like a commencement
ceremony where you get your citizenship
yeah have you guys ever been to one nah
I went with my mother-in-law and like
that [__] is makes you feel [__]
proud to be oh yeah it's like a
Chick-fil-A Sandwich actually no oh
that's like if they can improve it
that's what they should do but what do
they do though but like you you all sit
in the this giant auditorium at the LA
Convention Center and everyone's like
it's like a whole thing you get your
papers blah blah and then Donald at the
time Donald Trump was president and he
had his giant message and it was like a
video of him talking about like we're
welcoming you to be an American Baba you
know like some hurray [__] and then
people were kind of mixed like oh yeah
but he didn't say like Boo except for
the rapists and predators we don't want
you here yeah yeah but then some people
were like uh like just like kind of
rumbling a little bit but afterwards
they do like a yeah I think they just it
was like everyone starts applausing and
it's it's you just feel [__] my
patriotic yeah dude because you see what
it means to everybody there it's a
milestone they're excited to be there
and it's really cool especially they all
came from shittier situations that's
what I'm saying like why wouldn't you
want to be in the U.S dude especially
where the countries that they're coming
from like of course they're spoiled out
here we forget a lot of [__] yeah take
that [__] you come from a better country
like Sweden or something they don't yeah
they just stay there and they don't even
come here [__] it I mean like or like
Malta people like they're not coming
here I remember my boy uh got married to
his Canadian wife and then when they
were like changing her last name and
giving her documents of citizenship the
person at the office in America was like
you're getting your American like Visa
citizenship and green card like but they
were questions this is backwards most
people want to go to Canada that's so
sure you can't reverse this afterwards
they're like are you sure you want to do
this that's like downgrading yeah I I
don't like what is they say our passport
is one of the weaker ones really because
yeah there's like so many countries you
can't go to yeah you can't get automatic
visas yeah like apparently North Korea's
passport is more powerful than ours
because they can go to all these
different countries that we can't I mean
I don't know if we'd want to go to those
guys they just don't let them leave yeah
this will get you anywhere but you're
not going anywhere
[Music]
foreign